[Musique]
au son des mitraillettes et des sirènes
un petit groupe de personnes se
rassemblent devant le consulat général
de Russie à Montréal
une manifestation comme celle-ci se
tient ici tous les midis depuis le 15
mars dernier tous les jours depuis près
d'un an
un geste de solidarité envers l'Ukraine
aussi perçue comme de l'hostilité si tu
es
l'ambassadeur russe au pays soutient que
le Canada est devenu carrément dangereux
pour ses compatriotes
selon lui des personnes d'origine russe
ont perdu leur emploi d'autres ont été
menacés ou carrément attaqués des
informations que nous n'avons pas été en
mesure de corroborer
ceux qui sortent du consulat sont
parfois intimidés prétendants
catégoriquement les manifestants
certaines d'entre eux d'ailleurs sont
d'origine russe dangereux on attaque
personne on est pacifique aussi je me
sens très en sécurité Olga se sent plus
en sécurité ici qu'en Russie ou de
telles manifestations ne sont pas
tolérées elle n'a aucunement été victime
de discrimination dit-elle je suis
beaucoup de sport
partout de dire que le Canada est un
pays dangereux relève en fait de la
propagande selon Youri
les chiffres et l'éditeur d'un journal
destiné à la population russophone
rendez-vous à Montréal et publié une
fois par semaine depuis 1998
il accuse lui aussi l'ambassadeur russe
de faire de la désinformation mais il
avoue s'être fait insulter à quelques
reprises ces derniers mois Wasa
le journal déplore-t-il a même perdu des
annonceurs
qui le veuillent ou non dans certains
cas la vie des Russes au Canada a bien
changé ici Sébastien Desrosiers
Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]